oh go pee go go go don't look at me
don't look at me like that you just go
good tower go to the tower call stupid
biggie stop honking at me and go to
Tower this is that's a way to the tower
hey boy point point point point I'll dig
out the rest of that later and straight
down like a bow fluid is watch this guy
okay I did not expect that going back to
the surface
I've had it with this place I mean I'm
gonna come back to this chasm but when I
have more excavating ah haha who doesn't
love pork honestly Communists probably
haha stop it give me a chance to get
close to you so I can kill you that's
all I ask
that's my pickup lines room no it's not
it is not that is creepy though that is
not my pickup line for girls it's just
wrong then I don't even know half the
things that come out of my mouth oh can
I leap across the cavern do you dare me
youtube not dare myself here I go haha
yeah who is it who is it who's it what
was that sorry gonna happen
oh sure epic garden it's lava oh yeah
this looks cool I almost got burnt to
death but not quite can't get me urn wow
this is actually pretty cool look at it
gold
I'll go get you I'm gonna get you
oh yeah that seems like an impossibility
because meter 4 meter a Minecraft world
is like bigger than the diameter of
Uranus no no it's totally serious like
in terms of meters
if each block is a meter then it's wider
than Uranus sorry all right that's gonna
chur why won't these things die I'm not
again not again not
I hate skeletons I hate him
aah Oh Oh aah
is there another way to get ink and I
just stupid I'll probably stupid well I
don't answer that
don't ends Equus yeah but am i no don't
answer that question right in the
comments if you want to answer that
question and then i ban you from my
channel if I could do that I can't do
that just answer
now I stupid how dare you